il y a quelque chose de caché sélectionnez-moi qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est une mémoire mémoire mémoire de
ce que vous avez fait ce film commence comme une
sorte de simple film de braquage d'art puis se
transforme en thriller puis à la
25e page les choses la chose devient
autre chose bien que les gens  commencez par
penser que c'est un film sur la
peinture volée et regardez les bandes-annonces et
il y a une mise en scène d'une peinture volée,
il ne s'agit en fait pas de cela, il s'agit en
fait de souvenirs volés Elizabeth
va me tuer oh il ambia mon
personnage il ne se souvient pas qui il  est
correctement parce qu'il s'est fait enlever toute une partie
de sa vie et pas seulement ID
pas seulement un jour où ce braquage s'est produit,
puis il reçoit un coup sur la tête qui est
parti mais il manque quelque chose d'autre
et cela n'a pas de sens mais
quelque chose  énorme pas bien dans sa vie
rappelez-vous ne soyez pas un héros donc je suis un
gangster je suis un homme d'affaires et je suis
français que pouvez-vous lui faire faire quoi que ce soit
il y a un genre d'élément si dangereux et risqué
pour chaque être  à de l'
histoire mais nous nous sommes tellement amusés je
pense que cette partie se passe vraiment je
veux dire que nous trois sommes si différents
et nos personnages sont si différents et
il n'y a pas de véritable intimité c'est quelque chose
qui se trouve et je pense que ça irait carré
c'est garé  décalé et c'est garé sur le
plateau tu n'es pas amusant de t'asseoir là
pendant dix minutes pendant qu'elle l'hypnothérapie
c'est moi et c'est assez apaisant et si je
me laisse aller je pense que je pourrais m'endormir
assez joyeusement alors j'aimerais que tu fermes
vos yeux et imaginez que vous êtes dans un
ascenseur et maintenant vous êtes au troisième
étage en train de descendre et vous sentez que
peut-être vous ne voudrez plus jamais sortir
c'est si sûr ici si confortable si
détendu
Je ne veux pas parler à  Simon mais je
veux parler aux hommes qui
m'écoutent ce n'était pas tant l'
histoire de l'hypnothérapie ou quelque chose comme ça c'était
l'occasion de faire un
thriller rafraîchissant divertissant et sinueux avec
Danny c'est la proposition qui
m'a été faite  comme il était comme moi  regarde
ça, je ne voulais pas faire quelque chose
qui était très référentiel mais je
voulais qu'il ait une sorte de charge émotionnelle
aussi à un certain niveau c'est un jean
bender ça te dérange vraiment et mais
parce que c'est très précisément écrit  vous
acceptez cela et vous y allez, il y
a une situation incroyablement extrême en
Israël dans laquelle je ne peux imaginer aucun
hypnothérapeute de Harley Street
traitant avec vous savez ces
mecs violents et un vol d'art de 25 millions de livres et
ou pas aussi bien mais c'est quoi
le rend si intéressant opieop apprends à le
planifier ensemble elle a mis cette
bière ce n'est pas réel c'était une joie de
travailler avec le vincent cassell et le
james mcavoy Andy Danny Boyle et à la
fin alors juste être ballin chanson James
et Danny  c'est super
Elizabeth
j'ai quelque chose à te dire
tu es prête
je me souviens